amazing spider-man news spent a while
now we have some spider-man news first
when the amazing spider-man due out in
summer 2012 one of the villains is the
lizard you got proto goblin also but
ultimately we're all like dude I want to
see the lizard show us the lizard and
now we have concept art of the lizard
someone sent me the link to like oh dude
check it out I was like alright let's
see all right in the okay kind of looks
like Voldemort doesn't he I don't know
is there something Voldemort ish about
him either that or he's a Goomba from
the Super Mario Brothers yeah movie that
never happened so it's either gonna be
like dr. Connors or dr. Connors hey
yay okay sorry about that I probably
shouldn't reference that movie because
that movie never happened yeah the Super
Mario Brothers movie never actually
happened I mean maybe in another
universe the Super Mario Brothers movie
did happen but in this one that we live
in right now the Super Mario Brothers
movie never happened and so I cannot
reference a movie that never happened
apologies for the confusion but there is
something about him I'm torn like yeah
it does look like how a guy would look
if you did turn into a lizard that being
said he doesn't have the snout I guess
in the footage that they screened at
Comic Con he did appear to have this now
you know like the elongated face like a
lizard has and this one he doesn't look
like he does have it although I've seen
instances like this in movies and TV
shows and whatnot where it looked like
someone has just a mouth in the front
but ultimately it does open on the sides
like a Goomba from the Mario Brothers
movie that never actually happened and
there's a theory that maybe it's a
progressive thing maybe this isn't the
final phase of him being the lizard it's
like you know phased eight of ten
like he doesn't mutate in one step like
he did in the spider-man cartoon it's a
progressive thing as the movie goes on
which all right that'd be fine I might
just about this and then when I
see the trailer I'm gonna be like oh
it's so awesome the lizard he's jumping
around is the lizard but for right now
I'm thinking
can't help but think it and it is just
concept art you know I mean maybe they
had this concept art and they tried it
out there like I know let's give them
elongated snow so we're going to get
that in the movie I mean shoot I can
find concept art for the Dark Knight
Joker looks nothing like the Joker we
got in the Dark Knight so concept art
ultimately means and maybe it looks like
that that's it it's a big maybe picture
so now that we have this concept art of
a maybe picture that the lizard might
look like a Goomba slash Voldemort the
new spider-man movie what do you think
of it comment below let me know and as
always if you liked what you seen here
and you want to see more click right
here to see more